yeah so I think a lot of it is armed you
know the one thing that always keep in
mind is really open communication and
you say it the way it is and you know
you try to get people excited about it
or think with you and and again you're
setting an example trying to be a role
model in to give them you have to give
them a background you know at least new
folks you have to give them a background
while you're there I think in Genoa it's
it's fairly easy because we have been
you know somewhat successful so it's
easy to get people to say okay you know
sometimes it's also easy to come from
you know with people that you know
really didn't like where they were and
you say okay I can take you there and we
can do something and why don't you try
this out and these are great
opportunities you know but you know I
think it takes a lot of energy you know
every day to to really drive people that
way and sometimes you're lucky you know
I've had people that they're already
running way ahead of me you know which
is great